un proviseur et des enseignants au
milieu des prés l'image peut paraître
insolite
elle est pourtant symbolique de cette
cave ou lui l'équipe du lycée une
rencontre informelle pour des élèves qui
étaient tous ailleurs l'an dernier c'est
permet de faire connaissance avec les
autres copains et puis est ce à prendre
différemment que en dehors du collège et
du lycée
toi tu dire encore collège et il n'y a
pas que les élèves qui changent
d'établissement qui ont besoin de créer
des liens à l'image de ce jeune
conseiller principal d'éducation dont
c'est le premier poste se permettre
connais tout le monde en même temps les
nouveaux élèves aussi de connaître ses
collègues ses futurs collègues non c'est
valorisant enfin pour tous pour tout le
monde c'est bien tous les établissements
le faux-pas j'ai de la chance d'être là
où je voulais être
ça se passe comme ça ces jeunes filles
vont préparer un bac professionnel des
dalles à personne elle n'imaginait pas
débuté l'année en faisant du tir
mais puisque le biathlon est enseigné
dans l'établissement on leur fait
découvrir ce sport pratiqué par certains
de leurs futurs camarades
ça leur permet de comprendre pourquoi
ils vont voir à certains moments dans la
cour des jeunes gens partir avec des
skis de fond partir avec des carabines à
l'entraînement et ce sont des jeunes qui
appartiennent au même lycée que et c'est
l'occasion pouvoir échanger sur les
différentes pratiques qui sont dispensés
dans le lycée vous saviez ce que c'était
j'étais pourquoi et vous saviez qu'il
est enseigné dans le lycée un an chaque
pas non plus donc ça sert aussi à ça la
journée et pour donner encore plus de
sens à ces deux journées les activités
pratiques et leçons sur le site de la
perdrix la ou en partenariat avec
l'association qui gère les lieux les
élèves du lycée ont construit cet
observatoire exemples de travaux
pratiques
je pense qu'un élève qui arrive
aujourd'hui qui voit qu'il s'inscrit
dans un lycée où ces cas il ya une
réalité derrière il ya du concret il ya
des élèves qui ont fait des projets
qu'on menait des actions sur deux ans et
qui voit vraiment le résultat qui existe
je pense que c'est vraiment intéressant
et c'est surtout très motivant
la semaine prochaine rendez vous pour
tous au lycée plus motivé que jamais